matt's making his 12th start of the
season he's has a
team leading six wins as he takes the
mound today against the astros he's
making a second career start versus
houston the other one coming
last month that was down in minute maid
park he earned that win but he only
threw
five innings and gave up eight hits
against the astros
now two bay having a good series four
for seven in the astros first venture up
to buffalo that's the one two and altuve
drills this one deep down the left field
line ball is hooking guriel is back
looking up
and that ball is gone a leadoff home run
for jose altuve
and the astros have a one to nothing
lead his fifth lead off home run of the
season and his 19th
of his career bats will throw off speed
early and counts but he tried to sneak
that cheese on the inside corner and
jose altuve here with this one o'clock
start in
buffalo up and ready to turn on it and a
big celebration from garrett stubbs
in the dugout a little tapper gloved by
mats as he makes the toss to first to
get carlos
for the first out of the inning well
matt's now with two outs after the home
run by altuve will face jordan alvarez
and he goes the other way this time it
won't be a home run but that'll be a
little base hit to left field for yordon
so he'll be a two out base runner
astro's second hit of the game
garielle coiled as he waits the payoff
pitch
and it's high ball four so the astros
have two on with two out
for kyle tucker first and second
two outs of man in and there's a ground
ball
nice play by machete spins and fires and
stephen mats is out of it and they are
set to look at
luis garcia for the first time
another very good right arm from that
houston
farm system luis garcia's 4-0 with a 157
era in his last four starts
he threw a career-high seven innings of
one run ball in his last start that was
against the red sox
he's got a 260 era through his first 10
career starts which is the seventh
lowest
in astros history the 0-1
that's a ground ball hit up the middle
altuve to the left of second fields and
throws to first in time
two out no one on for the designated
hitter vladimir guerrero junior
garcia's one-two swing and a mess got
him on the cutter
and that's the first strikeout for luis
garcia completes a one two three inning
and after one in buffalo astros won blue
jays nothing
mccormick getting the start at center
field today miles straw
not in the lineup there's a ball drilled
to left field all the way back goes
guriel looking up
gone home run the chasmanian devil
hits his fifth home run of the year and
the astros lead this game two to nothing
well apparently the astros are going to
lead off every inning with the homer
they got the memo mccormick got the memo
with the wind blowing out to
to center field today get the ball in
the air mccormick put a great pass on it
kind of fits the idea of a chesmanian
devil
just turning on a fastball
yeah there you go jones starting at
first today with gary l d h
he's five for 29 as a big leaguer 172
average no homer's three driven in
here's a 1-1 and jones hits it pretty
well toward right center field headed
toward the cap and that's going to split
the gap and one hop the wall
and jones on his way to second base
he'll stop there
with a double hernandez a third panic at
first one out for lourdes guriel jr left
fielder
he's been swinging about much better of
late his average up to 262.
there's a drive that's going to get
caught out in the outfield by mccormick
and
tagging at third and coming in as taos
hernandez and the blue jays have cut
into that lead
it's now 2-1 houston was looking to
capitalize on a nobody out bases loaded
situation
tucker who has hit lefties pretty well
throughout his career at 209 this year
against left-hand pitching
first pitch to tucker a big breaking
ball is hit to shallow left center field
and that's a base hit bregman will score
the astros are going to send alvarez
here's a play at the plate he's safe
tucker drives in too the astros lead 4-1
great job by jordan
to read this base hit off the bat of
kyle tucker here's the 3-2 pitch to
simeon it's a
shot up the middle backhanded by altuve
he goes to third bregman tags them out
what a play by the astros infielders
altuve's
momentum took him that way and a bullet
throw to
bregman who was just getting over there
in time
great heads up play by jose altuve that
ball was smoked up the middle by simeon
it's just a heads up play by the astros
told you they're the finest fielding
team in the american league they've only
committed 21 airs the fewest american
league
danny jansen exits the ball game with a
right hamstring strain
and as you mentioned reese mcguire now
in the ball game
on the ground right side diving stopped
by altuve
what an inning defensively for jose he
gets beau bashed on a great defensive
play for out number two
full-out dive to get that ground ball
shet making a bit going the other way
altuve
diving into that shallow right field
area comes up firing
great play astros lead by three with two
men on
teles grounded out as last time up big
left-handed
hitter garcia set here's the pitch
breaking ball got him
strike three as he snuck that slider low
and in
and teles swings right over the top five
strikeouts now for garcia
and escapes trouble wire hitting 231 in
16 games 286 on base percentage no
homers in an rbi for maguire who started
last night
the 01 and that's lifted in the air to
the left side
over toward the line alvarez and foul
territory makes the catch
and then bangs into the wall nicely done
by yordon staying with that not a whole
lot of foul territory
deep down the left field line at salem
field and alvarez had to use all of it
to come up with the ball
another opportunity to lose that runner
the one-two to altuve and he hits it in
the air to left
guriel coming in still coming in and
makes the sliding catch
maldonado back to second and that is the
first out
he barely got to that one a late jump he
was fooled
by the swing about to be oscar hernandez
the batter
he singled and scored in the second
struck out in the fourth here comes the
kick and the 2-2
swing and a miss there was a really good
cutter starting down out of the zone and
that's seven strikeouts
for luis garcia two away randall griczyk
will take his turn
oh for one strikeout on a walk
strike three call on the outside corner
gritchik thought it was ball four
but he goes down looking that's the
eighth strikeout for garcia inning over
so maldonado to the plate now hit his
second career grand slam on friday night
cued off the end of the bat that'll be
bouncing away from teles maldonado's
still out at first base didn't get down
the line and that cost the astros a run
hold the phone though yeah take a look
at that
you're the astros boy a ton of english
on that
ball is safe indeed so the
call on defeat is over chair here's
guriel he's reached all four times two
walks two singles
astros lead at five to one one one to
guriel and that's hit hard
and in the left field for a base hit
that'll score bregman
and the astros lead is six to one yulie
his third hit today
and his 41st rbi of the year he's
reached all five times in this ball game
guriel
and the grounder off the end of the mat
outside quickly to second for one and
that's all they'll get
so guerrero is retired at second a run
comes in to score
brandon has walked and struck out twice
there's a base hit up the middle that'll
mark home
bo buchet as the blue jays are
scratching and pouring here in the
eighth
and now you get into the the meat of the
blue jays order starting with marcus
simeon
uh one two and that's a ground ball left
side
charging bregman picks it off to his
left throws to first and that
is the ball game the houston astros take
two out of three and buffalo from the
blue jays